improv can be found everywhere in cinema
and not just in comedies it can be
dramatic or scary or even in a David
Lynch flick some of the most famous
scenes in Hollywood history have been
completely off the cuff
Judd Apatow first made a name for
himself in the entertainment industry
through stand-up comedy and later
through television after working on the
shows Freaks and Geeks the Larry Sanders
show and Undeclared aptow directed the
40 year old virgin as his feature film
debut Abigail's filmmaking style has
been largely defined by improv comedy as
can be seen in the lionarama bonus
features frequently included on the DVD
releases of his movies improv is present
on set in most scenes Aptos scripts
provide comedic situations and setups
but he frequently allows his actors to
play around and generate different punch
lines improv can be found throughout the
entirety of the 40 year old virgin but
one scene in particular stands out from
the rest the famous waxing scene as
shown in a behind the scenes featurette
Steve Carell was actually waxed on
camera to capture his authentic
reactions five cameras were used to
record the whole scene at once as Corell
and the other actors in the scene and
provides reactions in Apatow's typical
lanorama style wow
I'm sorry I really don't swear this much
okay you know what you know I got a weak
stomach that's all I could really take
as Apatow explained on the Rich Eisen
show Corel who co-wrote the script with
apatel insisted on getting waxed for
real it was also revealed that the woman
who waxed Corel had never done it before
and lied to them during her audition the
number one rule when he wax is you don't
put the wax over the nipple because you
could just rip someone's nipple off
director John cassavetti's faces was a
game changer for independent film when
it was released in 1968. casavettes was
already a successful actor known for his
roles in films like The Dirty Dozen the
killers and Rosemary's Baby according to
the biography accidental genius by
Marshall fine cassavetes used the money
he earned as an actor to self-finance
his own films he was able to work
completely outside of the studio system
and create films that placed all
emphasis on character and acting while
striving for authenticity though it was
his fourth time directing faces was
cassavedi's first film to break through
to audiences and critics in a major way
the film earned three Oscar nominations
for actors Seymour Castle Lynn Carlin
and for original screenplay as good as
his starting material was it became
stronger as it was explored through
rehearsals and on the set cassavetes
gave his small troop of actors a
concrete script but afforded them the
freedom to explore the material from
different angles cassavetes himself
contributed to this improvisational
Spirit while behind the camera by
shouting out direction to the cast
mid-seam which he then had to figure out
how to cover up in post-production at
over two hours long faces is composed of
just a handful of long scenes each which
probed deep into the human psyche
Angel not to be confused with the
popular TV show of the same name is a
sleazy exploitation film from 1983. the
sensationalized plot follows a 15 year
old high schooler Who moonlights as a
sex worker she finds herself in danger
when a deranged serial killer begins
targeting her fellow co-workers the
unnamed serial killer character was an
early role for actor John deal who would
later appear in bigger projects like the
shield and Stargate as explained by Joe
Bob Briggs when he hosted Angel for an
episode of his the last Drive-In series
deal was responsible for improvising the
film's single most memorable moment he
had zero dialogue in the film so deal
faced a major challenge when it came to
making his character memorable and
effectively disturbing in only a handful
of scenes during auditions director
Robert Vincent O'Neill simply asked the
prospective actors to be creepy without
speaking deal Rose to this task by
bringing an egg with him poking a hole
in the top with a knife and sucking the
Yoke out before crushing the shell
against his mouth O'Neill was so
impressed by Deal's improvised audition
that an egg-sucking scene was added into
the movie
I never thought to fail give the man
something to suck on and he's happy
and director Mike Lee's 2004 drama Vera
Drake the titular character is a working
class family woman who provides
abortions unbeknownst to her family at a
time when the practice was illegal in
the UK Imelda Stanton earned an Oscar
nomination for her lead performance Ann
Lee earned two Oscar nominations in the
directing and writing categories while
the first two nominations were well
deserved the third likely came as a
surprise considering the film didn't
have a screenplay at first improvisation
is at the heart of Lee's directorial
approach Staunton explained that all she
knew at the start of the project was
that it would be set in the 1950s and
that it would explore the subject of
abortion as well as
if you were to have the child would you
keep it or have it adopted
from a blank slate as she and Lee began
rehearsing and improvising the piece
from scratch for a full six months
Stanton had never improvised before but
dove into the deep end and ultimately
found the process exhilarating the
film's standout scene is the birthday
party in which the police unexpectedly
arrived and Vera's secret activities
come to light as revealed in the book
Mike Lee on Mike Lee none of the actors
playing the family had any idea that
police were about to show up only stunt
knew that her character was performing
abortions at that point and the shocked
reactions of everyone else were 100
authentic in the book Lee described the
scene as the result of an improvisation
that ran for 10 hours straight
I don't understand it
I don't expect you to sit
Quentin Tarantino is highly valued for
his skills as a writer so his sets are
rarely home to improvisation but there
have been a few exceptions one of the
biggest improvised moments arose out of
an accident during the filming of Django
Unchained during one of the film's most
intense scenes Calvin candy played by
Leonardo DiCaprio rants about phenology
and forcibly auctions off broomhilda
played by Kerry Washington DiCaprio told
ABC news that a glass shattered and cut
his hand when he slammed the tabletop
the delayed moment when he realized he
was bleeding was kept in the final edit
and DiCaprio was able to stay in
character and finish out the scene as
his hand gushed blood the bloody hand
was incorporated into the rest of the
sequence with candy even smearing his
blood all over broomhilda's face at one
point it's entirely possible that his
wound was cleaned and fake blood was
applied to his hand instead of DiCaprio
rubbing his actual blood all over
Washington's face but the idea at least
stemmed from The Unexpected injury
from the very first scene of Apocalypse
Now the production was already unfolding
in an unorthodox manner the opening
scene which finds Captain Willard drunk
and freaking out in a hotel room wasn't
originally in the script it was entirely
improvised by Martin Sheen while he was
liquored up for real
during an appearance at the Dubai
International Film Festival many years
later Sheen explained that the scene was
shot on his birthday and that he had
spent the entire day drinking before
shooting even started he was open about
the fact that he was in the throes of
alcoholism at the time and didn't get
sober until 1989. Shane described his
mental state during the filming of that
scene as being extremely precarious he
recalled I was so fragmented I didn't
have a clue who I was I said let's film
this I was so hopelessly drunk I
couldn't stand up but I had a sense that
I could deal with this demon he
described his performance as being less
about that character of Willard and more
about his own personal struggle with
addiction director Francis Ford Coppola
tried to stop him in the improvised
scene when he accidentally broke the
mirror and injured his hand but Shane
insisted on finishing the scene on his
own terms the blood that pours from his
hand and stains the bed sheet was 100
real
the 1996 movie secrets and lies tells
the story of a well-off black woman who
discovers after her adoptive parents die
that her birth mother is a working class
white woman it became one of the most
lauded films of the year it won three
awards at the Cannes Film Festival
including the Palm Door was nominated
for five Academy Awards and to come
through Baptist including the best
British film award and did one for
original screenplay but as is usually
the case with director Mike Lee's films
there was no screenplay when filming
began Lee spoke at length about the
creation of secrets and lies during an
appearance at film at Lincoln Center he
explained that he assembled his cast
before any characters or even any real
semblance of the plot had been formed
Beyond knowing that he wanted to explore
the subject of adoption together they
improvised what Lee described as the
whole world
from which we are then able to distill
and structure the film the moment when
the mother-daughter strangers meet for
the first time is heartbreaking in its
realism and simplicity as the two sit
side by side in a diner the camera
captures their entire interaction in a
single long take that lasts for about
eight minutes before cutting Lee's
improvisational approach enables a
lengthy dialogue heavy scene such as
this to unfold naturally in a way that
wouldn't be possible otherwise
no
you'd have enough to say that darling I
know
Sydney lumet's Dog Day Afternoon tells
the true story of a man who attempts a
bank robbery so that he can afford
gender affirming surgery for his partner
Al Pacino and John Casale Stars the bank
robber and his accomplice respectively
and the two had just starred together
the previous year in The Godfather part
2. lumet was a filmmaker who previously
held a strict no improvisation policy
but Dog Day Afternoon changed his entire
mindset lumet explained in his book
making movies that Frank Pearson's
adapted screenplay was used for the
structure but the dialogue was largely
thrown out in favor of allowing the
actors to improvise their way through
scenes with utmost naturalism being the
goal about 60 percent of the final film
was fully improvised when speaking to
Larry King on CNN Pacino confirmed that
even the film's biggest and most iconic
moments came from improvisation the most
well-known scene where he shouts Attica
and Riles up the crowd of onlookers was
completely improvised America
the idea of invoking the real-life
Attica prison Uprising as a thematic
connection to the bank robbery came from
lumet's assistant director Bert Harris
one of John cassavedi's greatest
achievements as a filmmaker was his 1974
drama A Woman Under the Influence
casavettes and Gina Rollins his
real-life wife and favorite Leading Lady
both earned Oscar nominations for their
work this character-driven story of
domestication Marshall's strife and
mental health struggles unfolds with
cassavedi's typical long and winding
scenes performed exhaustively with Hyper
realism as Kent Jones wrote in an essay
for the Criterion Collection the film
defies a Century's worth of film Theory
screenwriting tips and Film School
Orthodoxy in the book cassavetes on
cassavetes the director revealed that
his unorthodox process meant that a
woman under the influence took more than
three months of shooting with six day
work weeks to complete some believed his
films to be 100 improvised but he
dispelled that notion saying instead
that he always brought the cast to
complete screenplay only then would it
morph significantly as scenes changed
and evolved he described the process as
sticking to certain lines while allowing
the actors to interpret them however
they saw fit and then build upon the
material he wanted the actors to respond
to whatever happened in the moment as if
they were reacting naturally in real
life cassavetes added it really is a
product of a group of people coming in
and interpreting their roles really
truthfully interpreting their roles
everything that Gina did she did herself
I don't try and control the scene which
is often confused in our kick
Kramer vs Kramer tells the messy and
honest story of a couple's divorce and
their battle over the custody of their
child Dustin Hoffman and Meryl Streep
are in Peak form as the two halves of
this destroyed marriage both took home
Oscars for their performances as part of
the film's five wins in nine total
Academy Award nominations I'm leaving
you honey please I I can't hear Robert
Benton's oscar-winning screenplay
provided a wealth of Juicy material for
the actors to sink their teeth into but
as a director Benton brought a sense of
spontaneity to the table that Hoffman
fully embraced there are various
instances of improvisation that can be
spotted throughout Kramer vs Kramer the
most noteworthy ones arise in explosive
scenes between Hoffman and Streep some
of Hoffman's improvisation crossed the
line like when he slaps Streep right as
a take started and smashed a glass
against the wall beside her head near
the end of the scene without warning he
also improvised some cool lines that
doubled as insulting personal comments
about Streep's boyfriend fellow actor
John Cazale who had recently died of
lung cancer also Force genuine reactions
out of her Hoffman used similar tactics
on eight-year-old actor Justin Henry as
well who became the youngest Oscar
nominee ever Henry was never given a
script and his scenes were entirely
improvised
the action-packed police story is a Hong
Kong Kung Fu crime film from 1985 filled
with Goofy humor and jaw-dropping stunts
in equal measure Jackie Chan not only
stars in the lead role but also co-wrote
and directed the film delivering one of
the greatest films in his all-around
impressive body of work the film's
lengthy opening action sequence begins
with the shootout moves to an explosive
car chase then progresses to Chan
chasing a double decker bus on foot all
of these dangerous stunts were precisely
coordinated but the stunt that concluded
the sequence didn't go according to plan
as Chan himself explained when the bus
stops three stuntmen were supposed to
crash Through the Windows and land on
the car parked in front of it but the
bus's brakes didn't act as anticipated
and sent the stunt performers Through
the Windows too early Landing Atop A Car
might sound extremely painful but the
slight springiness to the metal and the
added height of the vehicle were
preferable to slamming directly onto the
concrete far below which is what ended
up happening rather than squander the
stunt team's Pain by calling cut Chan
was able to stay in character and
improvise the rest of the shot
incorporating the accident into the
final film
after the big budget disaster of his
1984 Dune adaptation David Lynch three
teams with star Kyle McLaughlin for a
smaller film with a twisted original
script that only Lynch could deliver the
1986 film blue velvet is a nightmares
descent into the disturbing crimes and
perversions that Fester below the
surface of suburban America As Told with
Lynch's signature surrealistic style his
work rarely adheres to the rules of the
natural world and is often derived from
dreams the subconscious and through his
practice of Transcendental Meditation in
blue velvet music is a key component and
even inspired its title with the Bobby
Vinton song of the same name sung by
Isabella rossolini in the film another
important musical number occurs when
Dean Stockwell performs Roy orbison's in
dreams into a construction light in the
book Lynch on Lynch it was revealed that
a version of this scene was planned but
that the end result came about through
improvisation the initial plan was for
Dennis Hopper to perform the song as the
film's villain Frank Booth popper and
Stockwell began singing it to together
on set despite only Hopper being on
camera Hopper was so taken by
stockwell's performance that he stopped
singing and simply watched him finish
the song Lynch loved the result and
reworked the scene the choice to sing
into a construction light was another
spontaneous decision as Stockwell
mistakenly grabbed a light used by the
crew instead of the prop he was supposed
to use
after making husbands and before making
a woman under the influence director
John cassavetes released Minnie and
Moskowitz the film utilized his Unique
hypernaturalistic Style but injected it
into the structure of an old-school
screwball romantic comedy that astewed
all the rules the titular characters of
many played by Gina Rollins and
Moskowitz played by Seymour Castle
former troubled romance as colorful
supporting characters Breeze in and out
of their lives as with his other films
cassavetes gave his actors as much
latitude as possible to flesh out the
characters themselves as they were
shooting their scenes but by placing his
improvisational style into a more
conventional structure the framework of
a traditional romantic comedy cassavedis
was able to break through to wider
audiences with Minnie and Moskowitz as
opposed to his other films which were
frequently labeled by his critics as
self-indulgent and Meandering to a fault
given how meticulously choreographed and
executed the John Wick movies are it
might come as a surprise to learn that
improvisation still made its way into
John Wick chapter 3 Parabellum Mark de
cascos who plays the film's lead villain
zero revealed to vulture that his
character was written to be familiar
with Mr Wick's reputation but the cascos
wanted to push that part of his
character further in their first
face-to-face scene tacaskos began to
improvise by moving uncomfortably close
to Keanu Reeves to the point that their
legs were touching he explained I could
feel keanu's energy it felt like his
energy was saying what the because my
leg is touching his big Kudos and credit
to Keanu and Chad sahelski director
because either of them could have said
cut but Chad Let It Go and Keanu stayed
in character as the scene went on Reeves
picked up on what decaska's was doing
and joined in until the scene was
finished the cascos recalled there's a
beat and I hear Chad from the back go I
love it we're doing it and that's how
that take evolved
Mikey and Nikki is an exploration of a
toxic friendship from writer director
Elaine May the film follows two
low-level gangsters with a long and
complicated history that bubbles back to
the surface when Nikki becomes an
assassination Target may had a
background in improvisation as a part of
the improv comedy duo Nichols in May so
her Casting and providers Peter Falk and
John cassavetes in the two titular roles
was no coincidence May's screenplay was
written in an unusual style that was
conducive to her and her cast
exploratory approach the opening
sequence is a perfect example of this as
the first four and a half pages are
written more like a book than a script
background information character details
and future tense occurrences are
described without explicitly telling the
actors what to do or how the first lines
of the film are Nikki giving Mikey
instructions over the phone the dialogue
itself was left completely unscripted
base process for making the film
typically involved letting Falk and
cassavetes improvise with three cameras
rolling it wasn't uncommon for multiple
hours to pass between May calling action
and cut though the film is all only an
hour and 46 minutes long may shot a
staggering 1.4 million feet of film
stock which is equivalent to around 14
000 hours worth of footage
Killzone is a gritty police Thriller
from Hong Kong Simon yam and Donnie Yen
Star as a Police Inspector nearing
retirement and his incoming replacement
both of whom become obsessed with taking
down a crime Kingpin played by martial
arts Legends Samo hung the first huge
action scene finds Johnny and squaring
off in an Alleyway against wujin who
would later star in and direct China's
highest grossing film of all time wolf
Warrior 2. given the intense
coordination and danger involved it's
exceptionally rare to find improvisation
in a fight sequence but Killzone pulled
it off as shown in the behind the scenes
documentary the alleyway baton vs Knife
Fight featured extensive improvisation
but the alleyway sequence wasn't in the
script and the first cut of the film had
been completed without any fight scenes
in it Yen realized the movie was in need
of action so he took it upon himself to
get additional funding and spend five
days shooting the alleyway fight on the
Fly Yin explained that he would have
certain moves planned out in his head
but that he would Implement them in
different orders and combinations while
sparring with Jin on camera he explained
it's like musicians you jam you know you
see all these movements they're really
not choreographed
director Mike lean star David thulis
both took home the top honors in their
categories at the Cannes Film Festival
for their work on the 1993 drama naked
thulis plays a nihilistic Drifter
conspiracy theorist and all around
terrible person and a loose narrative
that follows his exploits through London
in the middle of the night as is always
the case with Lee's films the entire
project was born from extensive
improvisation research and rehearsals he
and thulas had collaborated twice before
on other projects but though list of
screen time was brief on both occasions
with virtually nothing other than
wanting to work together again on a
project in which thulas would be the
lead the two generated the main
character and improvised the story
through multiple months of rehearsals
Lee explained that he treated the
character of Johnny as a receptacle for
information and piled mountains of
research about various subjects onto
thulis this all came in handy and
allowed doulas to go wild in the
memorable sequence in which he befriends
a security guard and rants about
numerous subjects and conspiracy
theories such as the impending Y2K
hysteria and the theory that barcodes
were satanic
with 11 Oscar nominations and six wins
including best picture The Godfather
Part 2 managed the miraculous feat of
outdoing the original best picture
winning The Godfather at the Academy
Awards release just two short years
later this follow-up acts as both the
sequel and a prequel to the first film
as it tracks Michael Corleone's growing
ruthlessness while showcasing veto
Corleone's rise to power through
multiple flashbacks one of the film's
strongest and most emotional scenes is
the final confrontation between Michael
and his older brother Fredo played by
John Casale the scene was already
powerful in the script but it was made
infinitely stronger through an element
that wasn't on the page kazali's choice
to play the entire scene from a bouncy
low-backed chair was a perfect fit for
the scene the awkward position made his
outrage all the more pathetic and
ineffectual I I'm smart and I want
respect on a commentary track recorded
for the physical media release of the
film director Francis Ford Coppola
explained that the chair just happened
to be on the set and wound up becoming a
vital part of it saying there was
something about the chair that worked so
great for the scene the chair just kind
of made him be so limp and springy
sometimes you get lucky with a chair
they live as a 1988 Sci-Fi Action
classic from director John Carpenter
Roddy Piper plays a homeless man who
comes into possession of a pair of
sunglasses that reveals the world as it
truly is a capitalist dystopia ruled by
aliens disguised as humans what's your
problem and both of the film's two most
famous scenes were the result of
improvisation if there is any scene from
they live that the average person will
be familiar with it's the one featuring
the iconic line I have come here to chew
bubble gum and kick ass
and Piper completely improvised the line
the other well-known scene is the back
alley beat down between Piper and
co-star Keith David in an interview with
YouTuber rosatron Carpenter and David
explained that the fight scene was
shoved into the movie after Piper had
been cast Piper was better known as a
wrestler with the WWF where he went by
the name Rowdy Roddy Piper and Carpenter
figured that a movie starring a
professional wrestler ought to make use
of his physical abilities in a big fight
scene that lasts for a whopping 6
minutes the 1988 shooting script simply
read and we begin the fight in the alley
as NADA and Frank go at each other
followed by three mostly blank pages on
which only the fight continued and the
fight still continued as written with
all of the intricacies of the Clash
being worked out on location if you or
anyone you know needs help with
addiction issues help is available visit
the Substance Abuse and Mental Health
Services Administration website or
contact Sam hsa's National helpline at
1-800-662-help 4357
[Music]